pour commencer cette édition plus de
neuf ans après la disparition
mystérieuse au zaïre de philippe de
dieuleveult le gouvernement français
reconnaît ce soir que les révélations
d'un ancien officier roi pourrait
constituer un élément nouveau
cet homme qui ne parle qu aujourd'hui
parce qu'il se sent désormais en
sécurité affirme que philippe de
dieuleveult auraient été exécutés par
les services secrets du zaïre
jusqu'ici c'est la thèse de l'accident
qui avait été privilégié philippe
boisserie le temps passant tout le monde
s'était plus ou moins rangé à la thèse
de l'accident de la noyade dense et
rapide du plaza here
et puis voilà qu'aujourd'hui un zaïrois
à l'époque officier des services secrets
dans cette même région par le das hasina
nous étions convaincus que cette eau les
mercenaires
bon il nous faut à arriver sur le lieu
c'est là où nous avons découvert que
c'était une expédition qui était
autorisée par kinshasa vient mais
l'autorisation n'a pas été répercutée
jusqu'aux genoux à boma j'ai assisté à
leur capture
oui il y à monsieur héraultais chanel
qui sont morts pendant leur capture et
messieurs blocs mme ans est mort en
prison
le suites de ses blessures puisqu'il n'a
pas été soignée et le quatre autres ont
été purement et simplement exécuté à
l'époque cette région stratégique du
barrage d'inga aurait été l'objet de
menaces soient de l'angola soit de la
libye les militaires à irois aurait
commis une méprise
selon okito bébés nés qui se présente
souvent comme un opposant au président
mobutu deux membres de l'expédition
aurait d'abord été tués les autres
l'ayant été sur ordre pour dissimuler
cette première bavure
une version qui divise les proches des
victimes pas vous dire que ça me
satisfait mais malgré tout je suis
contente que la vérité parce que je
crois sincèrement ils ont été assassinés
qu'est ce qui vous permet de dire ça
aujourd'hui à ce qu'on nous a donné des
on a essayé de nous donner des tas de
preuves de la noyade mais qui ne
tiennent pas dit où j'ai travaillé ce
dossier pendant deux ans je n'ai pas lu
le livre il m'étonne dans tant de tels
propos après le travail énorme auquel
nous nous sommes
ivre et pour avoir une opinion
définitive et des bals gouvernement
français par lé gouvernement à erwan
qu'elle faisait pas confiance
au départ nous nous sommes fait
définitivement une opinion il s'agit
d'une noyade affreux ce soir le
ministère des affaires étrangères
français considèrent que ces révélations
pourraient constituer un élément nouveau
l'enquète est rouverte